the only thing I hated getting on
Halloween was peppermints from old
people peppermints remotely but I love
old people
we justwhen ghost-hunting so all I feel
right now is like this I hate that my
back is to an open room that had a lot
of activity in it earlier filled
Twizzlers
Twizzlers is moving into the cattails
game which was on a Red Vine person I'm
I'm liable to Halloween they nailed it
it's like celery with peanut butter
pouring out it tastes like adventure and
fart like a starburst the caramel
actually makes it loose a little bit and
it's low fat it confuses me
pumpkins if one of the M&Ms worked at
the Starbucks they would be this one
it's an interesting flavor I'll give it
that it gives a new dynamic to them and
em tastes kind of like weed weed with
dish so this is what people that like
candy eat to feel sophisticated this
could be potentially a gateway candy
pecan pie flavor
I wouldn't mind this with like a cup of
tea that estrella offensive on another
one this actually I don't like begun by
actually hate this one - like ice cold
any adult who eats candy corn I'm like
tastes like caramel to me better than
regular candy corn this is dentist candy
it tastes like white chocolate I like
white chalk you taste candy corn no if I
were watching a crappy movie unedible of
these I'd eat them all three musketeers
three musketeers have really good
commercials where they break the insides
red it's supposed to be blood this is
what blood tastes like then I'm in dude
oh is it strawberry maybe a little bit
of a cherry in there yeah there's
different just this food coloring in it
you get means like rich creamy frothy
fillings
I thought that nougat is what you call
like your little friend that tags like
ah that means a little new get your gaze
oh damn tangy boogies that look and feel
real not your regular gummy like snot
none of them are
I've never found a green booger in my
life this is like post cold boogers
they're very hard on the inside here you
got to work at it not like a real booger
lot better with a few chews there's not
a real booger texture a booger you can
shoot through you've had experience
doing boogers here I have I was a kid
once I'm an adult this super awesome
atmosphere made the candy taste better
and knowing that there's probably some
ghosts standing here wanting to eat it
and get creative of candies candies are
fun why shouldn't we try more being
creeped out while you're getting your
tongue creeped out - there's a lot of
fun didn't stop it that was bad I want
to get out of here